deep learning has enabled us to build
detailed specialized a i models
and we can do that provided We Gather
enough data label it and use that to
train and deploy these models models
like customer service chat Bots or fraud
detection in banking now in the past if
you wanted to build a new model for your
specialization so say a model for
predictive maintenance in manufacturing
well you need to start again with data
selection and curation labeling model
development training and validation but
Foundation models are changing that
Paradigm so what is
a foundation
model
well a foundation model is a more
focused centralized effort to create a
base model and through fine tuning That
Base Foundation model can be adapted to
a specialized model need an AI model for
programming language translation well it
starts with a foundation model and then
fine-tune it with programming language
data
fine tuning and adapting base Foundation
models rapidly speeds up AI model
development so how do we do that well
let's take a look at the five stages of
the workflow to create an AI model stage
one that is to prepare
the data
now in this stage we need to train our
AI model with the data that we're going
to use and we're going to need a lot of
data potentially petabytes of data
across dozens of domains the data can
combine both available open source data
and proprietary data now this stage
performs a series of
data processing tasks and those include
things like categorization which
describes what the data is so which data
is English which is German which is
ansible which is Java that sort of thing
then the data is also applied with a
filter
so filtering allows us to for example
apply filters for hate speech and
profanity and abuse and that sort of
thing stuff that we want to filter out
of the system so we don't train the
model on it other filters May flag
copyrighted material or private or
sensitive information
something else we're going to take out
is duplicate data as well
so I'm going to remove that from there
and then that leaves us with something
called a base
data pile so that's really the output
of stage one and this base data pile can
be versioned and tagged and that allows
us to say this this here is what I'm
training the AI model on and here are
the filters that I used it's perfect for
governance
now stage two
is to train
the model
and we're going to train the model on
those base data piles so we start this
stage by picking the foundation model
that we want to use so we will select
our model
now there are many different types of
foundation models there are generative
Foundation models encoder only models
lightweight models High parameter models
are you looking to build an AI model to
use as a as a chat bot or as a
classifier so pick the foundation model
that matches your use case then match
the data pile with that model
next we take the data pile and we token
is it
now Foundation models work with tokens
rather than words and a data pile could
result in potentially trillions of
tokens
and now we can engage the process of
training using all of those tokens and
this process can take a long time
depending on the size of the model
large-scale Foundation models can take
months with many thousands of gpus but
once it's done the longest and highest
computational costs are behind us
stage three is validate
when training is finished we need to
Benchmark the model and this involves
running the model and assessing its
performance against a set of benchmarks
that help Define the quality of the
model and then from here we can create a
model card
that says this is the model I've trained
and these are the benchmark scores it
has achieved
now up until this point the main Persona
that has performed these tasks is the
data scientist now stage four is tune
and this is where we bring in the
Persona of the application developer
this Persona does not need to be an AI
expert they engage with the model
generating for example prompts to elicit
good performance from the model they can
provide additional local data to fine
tune
the model to improve its performance and
this stage is something that you can do
in hours or days much quicker than
building a model from scratch
and now we're ready for stage five which
is to deploy the model now this model
could run as a service offering deployed
to a public cloud
or we could alternatively embed the
model into an application that runs much
closer to the edge of the network either
way we can continue to iterate and
improve the model over time now here at
IBM we've announced a platform that
enables all five of the stages of this
workflow and it's called Watson X and
it's composed of three elements so we
have Watson x dot data we have Watson x
dot governance and we have Watson x dot
a i
and this is all built on IBM's hybrid
Cloud platform which is red hat
openshift
now what's an x dot data that is a
modern data lake house and it
establishes connections with the data
repositories that make up the data in
stage one what's the next dot governance
manages the data cards from stage one
and the model cards from stage three
enabling a collection of fact sheets
that ensure a well-governed AI process
and life cycle and what's the next dot
AI provides a means for the application
developer Persona to engage with the
model in stage four
overall Foundation models are changing
the way we build specialized AI models
and this five-stage workflow allows
teams to create Ai and AI derived
applications with greater sophistication
while rapidly speeding up AI model
development